we have a voicemail number and that
number
is 219 to david p
we've talked about the faux border
crisis here is a
right-wing caller very trumpian guy
who continues to ask about the faux
border crisis take a listen to this
hi when are you going to cover the
border crisis
thank you listen we've been covering the
facts of the situation at the border one
of those facts
is that the biden administration they've
not handled the border perfectly there's
no
they've done nothing really on
immigration that's permanent yet
uh but the number of migrant children
who are awaiting being reunited with
their families has dropped dramatically
from march to april it dropped
dramatically
the the crisis is a crisis
concocted by public relations and
concocted by republican
communications offices and concocted by
right-wing media that's the simple
reality of the situation
we had a situation at the border and
immigration not dealt with
under the trump administration we have a
situation at the border
and the immigration situation not dealt
with under the biden administration
some improvements have been made under
joe biden but this was their concerted
effort
and the voicemail is proof that it
worked and there's polling that tells us
it worked even though you and i might
remember what was going on at the border
under trump what's going on under biden
and say
it's slightly better but not resolved
right underwhelming but that's the
reality it's slightly better but not
resolved
if you look at polling back in june of
2020
only 28 of americans believed that
immigration and the border
were a serious and top issue now
about a month and a half ago 48 of
americans
almost doubling believe that the
situation at the border and immigration
is serious and crisis level so yes
they decided hey we need to create a
scandal for joe biden
yes it's a fake scandal but it has
worked and it has convinced
millions of people when something goes
from 28 to 48
in american society that's tens of
millions of people that have been
convinced of something
okay it has worked and you know i don't
know what else this guy wants me to say
we've covered
what's going on at the border and it's
slight improvement from the situation
that trump left us
we have a great bonus show for you today
andrew yang
is going after a tabloid
for what he is calling a racist cartoon
that referred to him as a tourist we're
going to talk about that on the bonus
show today
small business owners in manhattan are
increasingly getting
unbelievably well located uh businesses
as a result of the pandemic we'll talk
about where who why and what the
implications are
and the texas house has voted to pull
funding from sports teams
that do not play the national anthem
before sporting events which of course
they don't actually have to do
but this is the latest virtue signal
from republicans it's something that
doesn't
really matter it doesn't really do
anything
for the middle class working people
businesses education it's nonsense it's
virtue signaling
but it probably pulls pretty well with a
lot of republican voters and so that's
what the texas house has voted on
we will talk about all of those stories
and more when producer pat joins me on
today's bonus show
get access instantly by signing up at
joinpacman.com
and remember that monday memorial day
now just a few days away
we will be doing a single day membership
bomb
explosion we're going to do a single day
discount off of memberships we're trying
to rebuild
some of the lost memberships over the
last couple of months due to kovid
if you want to be notified of that
absolutely perfect
membership special on monday just get on
my
newsletter which you can do so you can
do at davidpakman.com upper right of the
website you type in your email address
you'll be on the newsletter and monday
you'll be notified
of that special coupon code but for
people who are already signed up
we will see you in mere moments on
today's bonus show
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service
at privacy.com pacman i've been using
privacy for a little over a year now
you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free
and like i said you'll get five dollars
to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman